peut-être su voir publisac au cours des
dernières des dernières alors au delà
des publicités quel magasin à grande
surface ce qui nous disent qu'ils ont
toujours des rabais qu'elles sont ceux
qui offrent les meilleurs prix les
protège y voit réalisé une grande
enquête dévoile le tout au cours des
prochains jours dans le magazine alors
bon alors écoutez bien ça si vous
fréquentez cosco maxi super c de ce
monde on a un classement un palmarès
pour lui c'est mathilde avoir chargé de
projet qui est avec tout ce matin pour
nous a parlé bonjour on commence
toujours avec c'est un grande aussi ce
que vous avez attaqué 4,6 au moins
quatre grandes surfaces là vous êtes les
visites effectivement une enquête de
prix on a vraiment voulu comparer les
prix de ses principales chaînes que vous
avez mentionné dont cosco maxi compagnie
walmart superficielle qui disent offrir
les meilleurs rabais aux consommateurs
on a voulu aller valider finalement
cette prétention là on est donc allé
visiter plusieurs fois à plusieurs
reprises sur trois semaines
ok on a récolté au total 1600 prix d'une
centaine de produits donc autant
l'alimentation les produits nettoyants
de soins personnels
on a analysé tout ça on a mis ça aussi
en parallèle avec le modèle d'affaires
de costco qui est quand même assez
particulier et on vous présente donc ce
palmarès bon et ce verdict et l'étude
ben c'était donc au skoki rampal
remporte la palme des prix les plus bas
du moins pour la majorité des articles
qu'on analyse et donc sur les 93
produite de notre liste 43 était moins
cher au coach qu en moyenne vous allez
payer environ 12 % moins cher au cos
cool si vous achetez tous les produits
de cette liste là donc papier toilette
fromage viande ça va être là que vous
allez trouver les produits les moins
chers au cos cause c'est parce qu'à coup
sûr
presqu'à coup sûr du moins été pendant
la période où on a analysé mais
effectivement
il est possible que vous d'une fois à
l'autre vous trouviez des résultats
différents
mais généralement c'est là où vous
pourriez retrouver ces produits les
moins chers
même chose pour les produits de marque
nationale donc par exemple et kellogg's
cornflakes ou le beurre d'arachide kraft
savait tous que ce que vous allez
trouver les moins chers pour la plupart
du temps il ya des exceptions quand même
un bière corona au perrier ont été vus
moins cher ailleurs
bon ce que vous avez des surprise en
faisant cette enquête là oui la plupart
des nouveaux parents pensent que les
produits pour bébés sont moins chers ou
cosco qu'ailleurs nous on a eu la
surprise de voir que les couches les
lingettes par exemple on sont moins
chers ou wal mart
on a remarqué c'est également pour les
produits d'entretien ménager la
nourriture pour animaux et les décors
sont peuvent être assez important donc
par exemple nourriture pour chats autour
de 8 $ le 5 kilowatts contre 12 dollars
ou cosco les couches presque cents
chacune au walmart comptera 12 700 en
rabais ou casse cou dans mes économies
qui peuvent être assez importante sur le
long terme il faut être prêt également
quand on va chez cosco parce qu'on
vendredi puisque c'est prévu d'acheter
en grande quantité ou si même les
cochers ce que c'est les mêmes formats
de gauche c'est ce qu'on met
effectivement sans tabou ça peut aller
puis parlez nous des autres commerces
également l'eau qui ont fait l'objet de
votre enquête
ce père c'est arrivé au dernier rang de
notre palmarès en fait dans tous les
rayons analysés sont plus chers sauf
pour les produits de soins personnels
parce qu'une ancienne poste suffisamment
pour qu'on ait considéré cette classe là
en fait que vous achetez tous les
articles de notre liste au super si vous
allez payer 103 dollars de plus qu'au
cosco maxi compagnie en troisième place
c'est là vous allez trouver les fruits
et légumes les moins chers par contre
produits laitiers boissons de soya
produits de soins personnels c'est là où
ils sont les plus chers bon alors si je
vous comprends bien haut plutôt que
d'éviter de faire deux trois arrêts de
trois ans puisqu'il prend du temps du
carburant on a envie d'aller chez
les geckos ce qu au bout du conte mais
cosco comment comment fait on pour
pouvoir offrir des prix comme ça là 13%
dans un panier complet
oui effectivement mais il met en place
plusieurs tactiques disons pour vraiment
garder les prix les plus bas
c'est sûr que la vente de leur carte de
membre lors donne un avantage
considérable en plus de fidéliser leur
clientèle
malgré le coût de 60 $ pour la carte de
base en plus vous risquez de
d'économiser sur une année mais il ya
d'autres choses également un coffret
achète en grand volume ils renouvellent
constamment ses stocks ce qui fait en
sorte qui est capable de garder ses
coûts d'inventaire extrêmement bas ils
ont pas d'intermédiaire entre leurs
fournisseurs et eux et ils économisent
sur des aspects comme la décoration
l'emplacement de leurs magasins maisons
sont situées en périphérie des grands
centres donc il arrive comme ça il
connaît mes bons et ils ont une tactique
au téléphone ce monsieur n'à voir du
seuil avait éteint ou quand ils
négocient avec un fournisseur cesser la
guerre sinon vous me direz ce prix là où
je livre ailleurs c'est fini je vous
barre de chez nous alors ça ça a un
effet sur les rendements merci beaucoup
d'être noir je remercie mais bien savoir